today's topic a virginia cop apparently
did something bad
and everyone wants us to comment on like
finally okay we'll flip it
if you're wondering why the stop is
happening it's for a rear license plate
not being where it's supposed to be it's
not there it's missing as they exit the
car they're actually going to notice
that the rear license plate is taped to
the back window
so generally some people do that if it
falls off of the rear plate
and they don't have to screw so they
just tape it but that's what this stop
is about
traffic stop
driver roll the window down felony
put your hands out the window this is a
traffic
this is a traffic stop it's crazy when
you do a traffic stop the categories of
traffic stuff that you're gonna pull out
your gun
is if the person endangers the life of
other people
if he's driving excessively fast but now
if you don't have
uh your license plate that's not uh
draw your gun wow this is
this escalated very fast yeah put your
hands out the window
turn the vehicle off put your hands out
the window
i can't tell
put your hands out the window and turn
the vehicle off
put your hands out the window
he's not complying joe let me see your
hands
how many occupants are in the vehicle if
he gets out of his car
now because he's like what is going on
confusion he's dead
he's dead a hundred percent sure he's
dead
the way the cop is already hyped up for
i don't know what reason
if he would have stepped out of his car
out of confusion
that's crazy cops have training to to
know how to act in the situation
and they don't follow suit but we as
civilians
have to act a certain way or else
whatever happens happen open the door
slowly step out
open the door
get out the car
open the door slowly and get out
now keep in mind his hands are outside
of the car the whole time
so it's one of those weird things where
it's like you go to reach inside to the
car to open the door
it's a loser situation and then they see
something in your hand
oh no i'll always feel nervous maybe
he's also filming inside the car so he
wants everything to be seen
yeah of course as you should be the door
get out the car
keep your hands outside the window so
you want me to keep my
hands outside the window or you want me
to get out the
car because if i got to open the goddamn
door to the car i got to reach inside
so you got two officers screaming at me
two opposite things
keep your hands outside get the [ __ ] out
the car which one is it officer
gone keep your hands outside the window
dude
make it make sense get out the car put
your hands outside the window
get out the car put you sit down stand
up it makes me think of your parents
you know him and grandparents yeah yeah
look at me when i'm talking to you
look down what did you say what did you
say oh you're responding to me that's
the same
the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah it makes
me think of that other incident at the
las vegas hotel where the white dude was
on the floor
and the cop was like don't don't move
all right now get up
and the dude goes to pull up his pants
and then he gets blasted yeah
because he was on the floor laying down
but obviously he just got called out of
the room
so he didn't have his belt on it was
just interesting
all right so some key information okay
the kappu fire the pepper show was fired
after an investigation
also another thing to note okay and this
is this is probably the most damning
thing
apparently they have it on tape that at
the end of this traffic stop
they asked this man to keep quiet about
it and that there would be no additional
charges meaning if he didn't make a fuss
to the media
all right that they would make no
additional charges
do you have a car now
yo what guess what i'm gonna grab her
two i'm gonna obey get out of the car
get out of the car now
get in the car now get out of the car
now get out of the car sir just get out
the car
work with us and we'll talk to you get
out the car you receive our order obey
it
i'm i'm i'm honestly afraid to get out
can i
yeah you should be get out i'm afraid to
get out of the car
yeah you should be you took a safety off
fired i'm happy to fight why are you
holding the gun sideways
well it depends who you're talking to no
because probably he has uh
that's just holding it's like that
sometimes just because when you're
holding it like that
oh it's a taser yeah my bad it's a taser
you're being stubborn
violence you're not cooperating at this
point right now you're under arrest
right
you're being detained okay you're being
detained for obstructive justice
get it get out of the car now get out of
the car get your hands off me get out of
here
get your hands off me you know what
hands off it's not a problem
back up danny
sir get out of the car sir hey get out
of the car now
sir look i'm trying to talk about you
okay i'm trying to i'm gonna talk to you
just get out the car can you please
relax get out please relax
get out of the car right now there's
nobody that's trying to talk to me that
has a gun
drawn that's not hey i'm just trying to
talk to you i'm just trying to talk to
you dude
it's not a talk man you guys are goobers
how you treat a vet uh
i'm actively serving this country and
this is how you're gonna treat me
i didn't do anything whoa hold on what's
going
hold on
[Applause]
804 just deployed
get out of the car get out of the car
now
get out of the car now sir just get out
the car
get out of the car now
yeah oh get out of the car and get on
the ground now you're gonna get it again
i i don't even want to beat you take
your seatbelt off and get out of the car
get out of the car now
see one of the fears that you have when
you do this right and i think people are
like why isn't you going you're always
terrified that when your hands are not
in sight
they're going to be like he was reaching
for a weapon that's a real fear that
people have
one thing that you taught right during a
traffic stop keep your hands on the
steering wheel always visible
don't be reaching for nothing right and
so there is a bit of that fear on the
other hand he probably should have just
opened the door and got out
but it's not a simple situation that's
right but you see how unstable these two
cops are he doesn't understand what's
going on because
they're being super like in his face and
they're saying things that contradict
themselves
so obviously they're hyped up about some
[ __ ] no if i reach to my butt
i'm he did he did the best he could
often get out of the car
don't reach alerting don't reach in
there my hands are out please
please look this is really messed up
my dog is in the back my dog is choking
right get out of the car
take your seat belt option what are your
specialists corporate are you
i'm a lieutenant lieutenant get out of
the car take your seatbelt off and get
out of the car
you made this way more difficult it had
to be if you just comply
get out of the car i'm reaching for my
seat though fine take your seatbelt off
and get out of the car
straight on the ground straight onto the
ground
man let's go
let's go
you're on the ground you're getting
sprayed again get on the ground can you
please talk to me about what's going on
on the ground that's right now please
talk to me yo girl
get on the ground can you please talk to
me about yes sir no
you're not can you please talk to me
about what's going on why
am i being treated like this why are you
not cooperating get on the ground
why am i being treated like this running
my stuff
get on the ground right there right
there
what's that it's gum what the [ __ ] get
on the ground
it's gum sir sir can you just work with
us can i
just work with this lay down flat hold
up lay down sir
right now right now you want to take
up lay down you're gonna get taken
i agree all you gotta do is listen
all right halo 3 the one
in custody can you open up the window
for my dog
i ain't choking can you open up the
window please yes
yes we will clearly in the way that this
whole thing was initiated there's
something that seems to be off
like when you watch it you're like how
did this escalate so fast normally
traffic stops you don't just come out
bowling you're going
blazing because the license plate's off
that's very odd
so it escalated so quickly now were the
things that he did
that weren't kosher went towards benefit
i would agree
yes but also understand how many times
have people
reached for a wallet got shot reached
for something to open the door
got shot so you're primed with that
you know what i'm saying but i'm also
not going to know absolutely the fact
that you know yeah there are certain
things they do is combative but
you know it's just like when you're
dealing with cops man
it's like a lose-lose situation
sometimes you need not trying to go into
any of that it's just
you just get tired it's like yo i know i
didn't do
and why are y'all doing all this extra
stuff y'all want to get me out of my car
i'm in my uniform
i've been an upright citizen and you
won't
tell me to get on get on my knees so
there's a sense of pride that gets
kind of demolished when you try to do
all the right things but
those are my general thoughts anything
you want to say i have nothing
no all right
and he does come into a rescue situation
where that job is winnable obviously for
him day one
shouldn't want to or if they think it's
better to develop them it's not a big
deal that case keep them going and play
for a little while and i think
dewfella is the keyboard
[Music]
sir go back into your car i'll be with
you in a second
you're gonna check the registration on
this plate soon mister
[Music]
here
have a good day judge
[Music]
yeah could it be like that america
let it be like that it bursts to the job
you're not going to stop me because of
the traffic sign you're not going to
stop me because i blow my
blew my own look at the name and you see
what it is
yeah judge that's why when you ask for
your papers they ask you
what is your title
miss mrs mr doctor
judge all right doctor on all my papers
well i guess that's it for today's video
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below
[Music]
you